الحرب في اوكرانيا
سببت مشاكل على المستوى الانساني على
المستوى العالمي كيف تنظرون لهذه الحرب
اولا نحن ننظر الى المناطق التي تضرر فيها
الناس اكثر مثل موجه اللجوء الداخلي
الملايين فروا الى خارج البلاد ملايين
اخرون نزحوا داخل بلدهم لذلك تعين على
برنامجنا النظر في كيفيه دعم الحكومه
الاوكرانيه على الاستمرار في اداء عملها
فيما هي تحت الهجوم والقصف جزء مهم من
الدوله ما زال يعمل بما يعزز قدره الحكومه
على استخدام الوسائل التكنولوجيه الجديده
لاعاده تسجيل الناس في مؤسسات الامانه
الاجتماعي التي تديرها وايضا القدره على
ان نمول المؤسسات الصغيره مثل المطاعم
وورش العمل وايضا النازحين على اطلاق
مبادرات صغيره تسمح لهم بتثبيت انفسهم في
مناطق عيشهم الجديده ومره اخرى يتعلق
الامر بالحفاظ على الكرامه في تسيير شؤون
الحياه وليس
رهنها بالاخر وفي نفس الوقت على قدره
الحكومه على العمل ومعالجه اثار التدمير
والقنابل والعبوات والمتفجرات التي تم
تركها وهنا يساعد برنامجنا الحكومه على
التعامل مع هذا الامر وخلال شهور الاخيره
اصبحنا احد الوكالات الرئيسيه الشريكه
للحكومه في التمويل السريع لاستبدال
التجهيزات المتضرره في منشات الجهد العالي
مثل مولدات الكهرباء في المدارس وغيرها من
المباني التي كانت عرضه لقصف ممنهج استهدف
بنيه الطاقه في اوكرانيا لذلك كنا من
اوائل الممولين بما منح القدره لاوكرانيا
على اعاده بناء بنيتها الكهربائيه بسرعه
لان ملايين الاشخاص غير قادرين على الحصول
على الكهرباء لعشر ساعات او اكثر يوميا في
الوقت الرهن ولكن كما تعرف الحرب في
اوكرانيا اثرت على كثير من دول العالم
كيف يمكن ان تخرج الدول التي تاثرت
بالتداعيات بشكل مباشر من ازمتها
على سؤال هل هناك وسيله سهله لمعالجه
التضخم اسعار الطاقه والغذاء ولكن ايضا في
اسواق المال ونسب الفائده التي تتزايد
بكيفيه متضاعفه وقيمه راس المال في الدول
التي تقترض الاموال من الاسواق الدوليه
والتي يتعين عليها خدمه الدين لذلك فان
المستهلك يدفع اكثر والحكومات تدفع اكثر
للوفاء بمواعيد الدفعات وهناك اموال اقل
تحت تصرفها وتصرف مواطنيها انها ازمه
تكلفه معيشه والامين العام للامم المتحده
عند اطلاق برنامج عالمي للتعامل مع هذا
الوضع العام الماضي اطلق مبادره البحر
الاسود الكبرى بهدف تهدئه اسواق الحبوب
العالميه والتي تعد المنطقه اكبر مزودا
لها ايضا نحن بصدد مساعده الدول التي
تاثرت وتعاني من ازمه ماليه حاليا وفي
سياق اجتماع مجموعه العشرين ولكن مؤخرا
اطلق الامين العام ايضا خطه تحفيزا
بمشاركه مجموعه العشرين وايضا مؤسسات
التمويل مثل صندوق النقد والبنك الدولي
للتوصل لاساليب اسرع وانجح في مواجهه
الازمات في الدول المتعثره او التي تواجه
صعوبات في الوفاء بديونها فهناك 150 دوله
تعاني بشكل او باخر من الديون وهناك منها
من هو على بعد خطوه من الافلاس لذلك تتم
مناقشه الضخ السريع بالسيوله واعادتها
هيكله الديون وايضا اعاده التفاوض بشان
شروط هذه الديون بما يجعل الدول تدفع اقل
فحرب اوكرانيا مست مئات الملايين من البشر
عبر العالم حسنا اول شيء هو الاستثمار
والوقايه وحل الازمات مهم جدا هناك من
يجادل بان الحرب حتميه اعتقد انه لا يوجد
امر لا يمكن تجنبه عندما يتعلق الامر
بالجيو سياسيه لكن لا يمكننا دوما ايقاف
الحروب يعني من ان تندلع ولكن يمكن القيام
بالكثير لمساعده الناس على مواجهه
التداعياتها ينبغي الاستثمار في السلم
والامم المتحده تلقت الكثير من الانتقادات
بسبب عدم منع الحروب من الاندلاع ولكن في
مثل هذه الازمات نحن نحتاج لدعم الاسره
الدوليه وايضا اطراف الحرب للنظر في اسباب
استمرارها وكيفيه ايقافها في المنطقه
وايضا على مستوى العالم ولسوء الحظ يبدو
انها لن تنتهي عما قريب
وحتما لكل منا وجهه نظره لكن الدبلوماسيه
دور مهم جدا حيث يمكن التوصل لمكان يكون
مهيئا بكيفيه
معها الاطراف بالتواصل مع بعضها البعض
هناك حروب استمرت لسنوات بل وقود وانا
اصلي حتى لا يكون نفس الامر بالنسبه الى
هذه الحرب لان الثمن باهض بكيفيه
استثنائيه بالنسبه الى الاوكرانيين وروسيا
ولكن ايضا للعالم كله وخاصه العالم السائر
في طريق النمو فبعد الخروج من ازمه كورونا
يبدو العالم مرهقا بفعل ضغوط تلك الازمه
والان مع هذه الازمه الثلاثيه في الطاقه
والغذاء وقيمه راس المال والقروض نحن ندفع
الكثير من الدول السائره في طريق النمو
الى مصير سيء وحرفيا الى الافلاس ولا يمكن
لهذا ان يكون الحل لهذه المشاكل في القرن
الحادي والعشرين